this is what that scene looked like
behind the scenes
[Music]
and that's not a stunt double tom
holland got hit by this car replica 17
times then had to lunge himself forward
to remain horizontal for the rest of the
stunt
and it's not the first time tom has done
his own stunts
as a trained acrobat and gymnast he's
dropped hundreds of feet in the air and
is backflipped off a replica of the
washington monument
here are five dangerous stunts tom
performed himself
for 2019 spider-man far from home tom
trained with stunt coordinator george
cottle for five weeks to prepare for all
the film's stunts but the most intense
was this web swinging sequence with mj
played by zendaya spider-man's iconic
skyscraper swings have been a consistent
challenge in the franchise predominantly
created using cgi in the earlier films
but for tom the filmmakers leaned into
practical stunts as much as possible tom
had a body cam attached to him and both
actors were raised by a crane with a
wire rig to over a hundred feet
the two were then dropped and swung in
an ark with cardboard boxes placed below
them as a safety precaution
to capture the landing and takeoff they
were lifted by cranes to different
heights outside of grand central station
and madison square garden
and for close-up shots of them in midair
a large blue screen and wind fans were
set up in the parking lot of a brooklyn
school the interior of which was used
for peter parker's high school
according to zendaya the shot from the
hundred foot high swing wasn't included
in the final cut but the final shot
combined in-camera practical stunts with
digidoubles for seamless movements like
never before in the series
you might think the washington monument
scene in 2017's spider-man homecoming
was all cgi but that was really tom
climbing and leaping around to save his
friends
various sections of the monument were
replicated and built on a sound stage in
atlanta specifically the side of the
monument was built at an angle for the
initial ascent
then wires assisted tom in the practical
climb
with clever camera angles the filmmakers
created the illusion that the building
was actually vertical
tom then had to perform various jumps
off another replica that represented the
very top and the sides of the building
here he is doing a backflip off the top
into the air assisted with cables
and in this shot he's doing a backflip
into what's known in the stunt world as
a face-off which prevents injury upon
impact by landing flat on his back
for stunts that were impossible or too
dangerous to perform like swinging from
the helicopter the filmmakers used cg
but the movements were based on motion
captured footage of tom's actual stunt
work
this made the final cg shots appear even
more realistic and in tom's signature
style
later in the same monument scene of
homecoming spider-man is pulled
headfirst into an elevator shaft tom
considered this scene one of his wildest
stunts for homecoming it required him to
have his legs in a split position and
then nose dive off a ledge suspended
with wires
tom was initially hesitant about doing
this himself according to his stunt
double chris silcox on top of his nerves
tom had to wear a corset harness which
was so tight he was worried about
throwing up in his mask in the end tom
decided to attempt the stunt without
using the stunt double
[Applause]
in spider-man far from home tom wasn't
just dealing with heights but water as
well he needed to navigate quickly in
and out of both the canals and boats
during this battle with the elementals
the crew recreated venice as a sound
stage near london with exact replicas of
the rialto bridge
they also recreated restaurants and blue
green canal water
to pull off this sequence safely tom
practiced leaping across wider platforms
and a clip he shared on his instagram
for the actual stunt he was attached to
a wire while he ran across a row of
poles in the canal and finally pole
vaulted onto the bridge
tom later said he regretted not wearing
shin guards like the stunt coordinator
suggested
the water was practically manipulated to
create massive waves slamming into tom
as he fought the elementals
at one point he was rigged to a ratchet
and pulled backwards into the wall of
the bridge then soaked with thousands of
gallons of water he had to perform this
stunt twice
his stunt double greg townley stood for
a few takes when the wave initially
struck tom on the bridge which tom poked
fun at on his instagram
greg
tom described this stunt in 2022's
uncharted as the most difficult of his
career and for good reason the scene
required him to jump through midair from
one set of flying cargo containers to
the next
then get hit by a car and ejected from a
plane
the crew built a blue screen set in the
parking lot of the studio to help
capture natural daylight
this scene using crates was shot in two
separate sequences
for the first sequence when tom falls
out of the plane supervising stunt
coordinator scott rogers decided to
stage the action vertically to better
simulate flying through the air
the special effects team used giant
robotic arms to safely hold and move the
boxes
and tom was secured with wires as he
hung onto the crates and flew through
the air
for the second sequence when tom is
climbing back into the plane and jumping
crate to crate the boxes were held more
horizontally
and for this final collision with the
car
the team built the front section of a
fake vehicle which was replaced by a cgi
car in the final cut tom and the fake
car were attached to the same rig with
the actor wearing sets of wires to
stabilize him the rig pulled the fake
hood towards tom knocking him backwards
he then needed to remain horizontal
while flying out of the plane to get
this shot tom had to be fake hit around
17 times with this entire scene taking
several weeks to complete the result a
realistic stunt that matches the
excitement from the popular video game
scene it was pulled from
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you